[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es kein
rezept von mir sondern ein richtig
hübsches die erweitung zuckerfest
ich zeige euch nämlich in diesem video
ri eine stinknormale industrie
verpackung richtig hübsch um sein könnte
wie ihr seht ihr alles war für dafür
benötigen deshalb eine packung ist sie
das ist die standardgröße mit 20 stück
drin außerdem noch etwas klebstoff und
leser band hier habe ich noch
doppelseitiges klebeband das habe ich
aber hinterher gar nicht verwendet ihr
könnt einfach schauen was euch am besten
passt außerdem noch eine schere und ein
skalpell oder ein teppichmesser ein
geodreieck und dann habe ich noch eine
richtig gute seite entdeckt faces.com da
könnt ihr euch kostenlos schablone
ausdrucken
ganz wichtig ist auch diese vorlage die
findet ihr so nicht im internet die habe
ich für euch erstellt und euch den link
unten in die infobox geschrieben und wie
guter letzt habe ich hier noch eine
glitzer pappe auf den bastelbedarf ihr
könnte aber auch nehmen was ihnen möchte
zuerst immer ich mich um die vorlage die
wird einmal sorgfältig ausgeschnitten
dann geben wir sie auf eine messie tafel
und zwar mit der schrift natürlich nach
vorne und dann könnte sie hinten mit
etwas viel verband befestigen
[Musik]
sobald wir das mit allen tafeln gemacht
haben nehmen wir uns die glitzer pappe
und legen da dem leeren messi karton
drauf jetzt zeichnen wir uns die
umrandung der oberfläche und danach
sieht das ganze aus geschnittenen völlig
egal ob ihr da ein teppichmesser ein
skalpell oder einer schweren
[Musik]
mit messi packung später auch auf
bekommen müssen wir die öffnung auch
herausschneiden und hier müsst ihr
darauf achten dass ihr da nicht zuviel
einschneidet also dieser streifen in der
mitte der gehört noch zum rand den
dürften nicht mit beachten
[Musik]
das wird dann auch noch mal sorgfältig
ausgeschnitten und dann haben wir
insgesamt drei teile
[Musik]
jetzt kommt auf die packung reicht es
gebe also sparte auch am besten nicht
damit dass schön anklebt und dann kämen
wir die glitzer pappel direkt darauf
dann werden auch noch die ränder beklebt
damit dass auch passend aussieht und
nicht so halbherzig und danach geht es
weiter mit der innenseite der merci
packung hierfür auch wieder die
verpackung mit dem bleistift
nachzeichnen und ausschneiden
[Musik]
das wird dann auch auf die innenseite
der messie schachtel geht und yeti
wieder reichlich kleber verwenden damit
das ganze auch an den seiten nicht
aufgeht und dann drückt ihr das am
besten noch mal richtig fest an
[Musik]
dann habe ich mir einen button von der
seite presse.com von der stadt schon
berichtet habe etwas ausgeschnitten und
klebe das auch noch mal auf die
vorderseite
für die innenseite der mit die packung
habe ich mich für diese zwei symbole
entschieden und gebe sie auch noch auf
[Musik]
und so weit sind wir nun fertig jetzt
zeige ich euch noch mal dass wir die
oberseite der mit die tafel nicht belebt
haben denn daran erkennt man ja welche
sorte es ist und jetzt wird die
schachtel einfach nur noch gefüllt und
dann ist das ganze auch schon fertig
sind verschenken
[Musik]
falls euch diese geschenkidee gefällt
ihr das ganze sogar nachts macht ein
stück wir doch gerne eure fotos über
instagram ich würde mich sehr freuen
und wenn ihr kein video mehr verpassen
möchte dann lasst ihr doch gerne ein abo
da bis zunächst mal auf dieses kitchen
[Musik]